welcome to the continuing series of
academy dialogues it starts with us
we are continuing our conversations
about race ethnicity
history gender opportunity and the art
of filmmaking
hosted by the academy moderating our
conversation today
arts and culture journalist and radio
host elvis mitchell
in conversation with mexican director
and screenwriter rodrigo garcia
casting director julia kim and veteran
casting director
victoria thomas we look forward to your
conversation
okay thank you so here's the question i
want to start this off with
just because of something i've been
thinking about is trying to figure out a
way to kick this off
if there's a piece of sort of colorless
color
interesting color casting and that you
have a hope for what movies could be
so i'll tell you mine for example seeing
billy d williams and tim burton's batman
because he played harvey dent which made
me think maybe he'll get to play
two-face
and of course he didn't but anyway i
just wanted
something like that that you guys saw in
your lives
uh that made you think well maybe movies
because we get so much of the
information about ourselves
as as people in the world from from
movies i just wonder if there's any
moment that occurred to
any of you guys like that the most it's
it was a film called searching where
john cho
played a father and it had nothing to do
with him
playing an asian character but really
just about a father whose concerns and
worries about his daughter
were common no matter what color you
were
and that was a monumental moment to see
that breakthrough occur in a major film
i i think it might be obvious but i mean
i guess just
say hamilton uh
uh where uh the
diversification of that cast
and obviously portraying white
characters with
you know puerto ricans or black people
or whatever it uh
kind of brought a larger truth to what
they were trying to do with the story of
hamilton anyway
um so
it didn't feel so self-conscious to me
because i think it was getting at a
bigger truth about the creation of
of our country so i mean that that'd be
kind of an obvious
one for me i think i think generally
you know you're always very thankful to
see
people of color playing roles that are
that are unexpected and that are not
about the ethnicity itself that don't
have a um
i mean some movies of course speak about
the ethnicity itself
uh but just like julia said you know
when a character is
everything at the same time i think you
know to say colorblind casting
there's something imprecise about it
because
who you are including your ethnicity and
your color always means something
and will mean something to the character
so um
you know it's when when something comes
together in a character for who they are
but of course there's no denying also
who they are ethnically and racially i
think those are the characters that um
that stand out i can't give you examples
because
my brain is at that stage now
we'll move it off of that stage into
another stage but
because what we're talking about and
what you said so beautifully julia is
that
actually what you guys all want to do is
create a tone where casting is subtext
rather than text so we see these things
and the identifiers become
the character as much of the as much as
the ethnicity right
absolutely um i i think
we're on that kind of trend anyways i
think we're seeing more and more of it
so it's really encouraging um but
there's probably still more work to be
done and i'm sure we'll talk about it
i mean i hope you do because especially
in light of
the recent academy inclusion changes
to for best picture i guess i want to
get you guys to give your takes on
what you thought when you heard that
news and what you think it might mean
for
the future and let's start with you
audrey huh
um i mean i i think i think it was a
you know an excellent measure it was
overdue
i think uh you know obviously it is of
this moment but
you know the academy has been moving in
the direction of inclusion over the last
few years
um and i also think uh
you know there was a very good job done
of doing something that's specific
but also in its own way also inclusive
meaning it wasn't going to shackle
filmmakers you know there are many ways
to contribute
to a uh you know moving in the direction
of
of inclusion and and of diversity
you know without um
you know tying the hands of filmmakers
in such a way where it's
it would just be crazy i think it was
done in a
in a very appropriate way and and i
think it
was going to yield results it better
what's that right what are you going to
say no i thought
know they're besides the best picture uh
category of a requirement now i thought
the mentorship and the internships
are a really important part of uh
[Music]
instituting because uh
people of color don't necessarily have
either family backgrounds
being in the business or come from a
line of you know my dad was a
a.d and my mom was a costume designer
not as uh frequent i think in people
and communities of color um
i did feel i have to say when i when i
saw the uh and i haven't read it
to the letter but when i saw the uh the
requirements for best
picture and the uh uh the one
one actor of color be in the uh
in the uh yeah
i i i just i said i said to myself what
if i want to
nominate a movie about the amish i mean
that's i mean i kind of had
had a little bit of a hesitation about
that one i i i can speak to that elvis
if
if i may because that was like you
mentioned i'm i'm on the board so i was
you know at least part of of the final
processes in that
um i think you know you read precisely
the one regarding acting
but i think the the these rules
allow for you know for you to
for your your production to have
inclusion in different areas that
include everything from
casting to behind the camera to the
post-production
to the studio to the distributor there
are many ways to do
it and you know things were discussed
like you suggested you know uh
without you know uh betraying anything
you know the example did come up or what
if you're making a movie in iceland
about icelandic people
but i think i think the rules are
are uh you know not not loose but broad
enough to include that
and i think that will also probably be a
process by which
uh you know particularly uh
you know particular examples can be
addressed so that we don't end up
excluding that kind of movie okay
i read it over and um
i thought i applauded the effort i i
thought um
the requirements gave a lot of space for
flexibility
and like you said rodrigo it's not just
uh the acting part it's the material
it's the key department heads it's the
crew
so the comments that i read felt a
little knee-jerk reaction
um oriented but um i i don't think the
academy is looking to limit
creativity i don't think the academy was
looking to
look for reasons to disqualify a a
feature a film i think what they were
trying to do is spread the love
and also i think there's a lot of
diversity
and eclectic people entering our
business on a daily basis so i feel like
you'd almost have to find a reason not
to meet
two out of the four requirements in this
day and age but
um yeah i i think it's a process in
motion with really good intentions
because what we're talking about is
we're talking from the top
down it feels like there haven't been
that many changes but
for you guys as a creative people it
feels like that world has
it's kind of always been open and is now
just
almost impatient with us saying let's
move on to the next step let's have
john chill play at that and and the
ethnicity not be
the first thing we learned or the first
thing is spoken about it literally
because that's what happens
or so often characters of color
basically tell you in the first of the
lines
oh by the way so as if the audience
can't actually suck this out
and i'm wondering if that kind of
bedrock change of being able to
get people cast to get us past that and
make these movies look more like the
world
are feel more wholesale than they did
even five years ago
i think that it needs to look more like
the world
what i see and and i do see it i do see
more of what i see around me i mean i
was born and raised in los angeles so
diversity is not a big thing for me it
was part of my
natural environment so um
yeah i i i think as as rodrigo says it's
about time
but um i'm sure there's people who are
impatient and feel like the incremental
changes aren't happening fast enough but
i see a big change from when i first
started in this business
and to now i think television has been a
big
a big instigator of change a lot more
than movies and they started
earlier than movies and it's kind of uh
almost a mandate and most television
just in diversifying
their cast and uh so they've they've
taken the
they've taken this on and really really
run with it
i think you know elvis i think
especially in the case of
of directors you know there's often that
knee-jerk reaction well
why can't i do whatever i want to do you
know why can't i use the people i want
to use i mean that's just
you know the kind of thing that comes
with the dna of being a director but
again i think you know what i like about
this
and i'm now speaking as a filmmaker i'm
not speaking as someone who
you know is on the academy board and had
somewhat of a role in this
um you know these rules are also an
invitation
for people to think differently what if
this character was chinese
what if this character was this you know
it's
it's it's a little bit it's a it's it
sounds like medicine
but it's an invitation to think in a
different way
and i think that's what can be valuable
and that's where
you know directors can satisfy what
we're trying to do
but also satisfy themselves that
i'll do it but it needs to be a
guatemalan person okay well let it be a
guatemalan person
you know it's uh we have to find that
middle ground between the creative
impulse and the creative vision
and what we're trying to do without you
know as
vicky suggested uh making things
impossible for filmmakers
i'm glad you brought that up about
directors kind of wanting their own ways
to give you a chance to ask
vicky and julie this question you can
pretend to not hear uh probably going to
ask
this but when you are talking with
filmmakers who
do want things the way they want them
and they aren't being
i'll mess with this they're being stolen
about what they think they want
but your jobs really are to expose them
to ideas and to actors they may not know
about
and does that get to at what point do
they get to be easier for you guys as
cancer director to say well
look at him and i have them go well i
didn't see
an asian or a black person in that role
when did that really start to be
a noticeable change in what you guys
were i think in the last
several years um it used to be i think a
harder
a harder thing to uh to change i think
back in the 2000s or
the 90s or you know back back then but
um and so you know sometimes you have to
kind of come through a different a side
door
with uh directors if they weren't
thinking about a certain character being
whatever it is anything different than
what they
they had fixed in their minds you just
kind of try to introduce
someone you know after they've seen
several of the type that they're looking
for maybe you kind of slip someone in
and
it's a little bit different and they
kind of get to hear it and oh
okay i didn't think about that or you
know just try to kind of go in a back
door in a way
uh being respectful of you know
what they want but also saying here's
another way we could
you know possibly go so it's really just
kind of
finessed a little bit kind of show them
something they did they might not have
thought of before or you know yeah
it's part of our job i think to do that
so
um we first read the script and meet
with the director
if it's someone we've never worked with
before and we hear their
hopes and dreams about it and and get a
good understanding of what they're
seeking for these roles but then i think
um trust uh in our in our ability to
bring
some fresh ideas to the table some out
of the box
ideas um if if they veto it
you know you tried but um i think it's
our job to
expand their mind because a lot of
directors i work with have written the
material as well and you become very
married to how you've been thinking
about it
and i think that casting directors are
super instrumental in broadening
that sort of narrow vision that they've
been carrying this whole time
and yeah i think that's why we like what
we do right vicky
it can be difficult but as you said
julia they
get very married to something i
understand it could be a personal
project it could be a
script about their life or their you
know their family and it's uh so you
want to respect that
you know and if uh
and hopefully whatever different uh
option you bring to them helps
accentuate whatever whatever
they're trying to communicate to to an
audience you know well i don't think
we're bringing in color for color sake i
mean i think like we want
the project to succeed and we have the
goodness of the project and the success
of it
in mind with implementing some of these
out-of-the-box ideas
yeah we're going where we go
i i was just actually thinking uh while
vicky and julia were talking that i you
know i have been in that situation where
i'm the writer director and
you know sometimes the casting director
will say well how about
elvis mitchell for that role and i'm
like no i just i love him but i don't
see it
and you know elvis mitchell stayed on
the list
and stayed on the list and they brought
him up and they brought him up
and i remember a couple cases
in particular where one of the first
names i
shot down and three months later it was
her
and she was great that it was her but
and this was on a pilot not material i'd
written but
you know that's that is where the
strengths of
being a director are so close to the to
the
the weaknesses of being a director you
know the tunnel vision
um and i think that's where you know
your heads of department and of course
casting
is crucial and uh and yeah i've seen
that you know those names just stay on
the list
and stay on the list and one day you're
like okay bring him in
just so you know i'm still waiting but
anyway um
i
if it's if it is that much more
difficult doing
he's getting these kinds of changes or
these kind of ideas
like he was saying four writer directors
what you're saying that he people who
live with this thing
and dreamed about it and been waiting
for years and years and just that i
wrote it with these people in mind and
and and and then sometimes
obviously you guys showed me oh well
that's
a much more interesting way to go but if
the writer director way tends to be that
much harder than just working with
somebody who's not a writer in the
project and depend directly
no they can rewrite it
they can go wait eureka you actually
opened my eyes to something kind of
different that i didn't think about let
me rework that character to fit in this
new introduction that you kind of
presented to me
so there's advantages to working with
writer directors too
i think i think you know in some ways
casting directors
are like editors in the sense that they
know
their job is so much about process
meaning time you cannot edit a movie
in a week with 17 editors you need
the 17 weeks and castings the same you
need to sleep on it whoever excites you
monday doesn't excite you thursday
and i think i think casting directors
have that
incredible patience and knowledge that
time will tell yeah very much so
because it's funny because you're saying
that vicky about um
certain kinds of projects demanding
certain casts i guess just found myself
thinking
is this going to feel like this this new
best picture things level
i've heard this phrase many number of
people so many times i want to get
behind it
uh people think it's the right idea
and certainly an idea whose time is long
since come
but also just there's the artistic ideal
that you can't
force chemistry uh
and then people will resist for reasons
that
you know whether they can they be valid
or just kind of a rationale
because they want to stick their ground
i wonder about
having those kinds of conversations with
directors and say well it needs to be
like this so it can feel like this
i mean i've i found myself uh
being the only black person in the room
arguing for a character to be white
just because i think it because i think
it makes
kind of sense for the a certain power
structure that you're talking about
within
the movie and i know i love the push for
diversity i'm all
all for it but there are times when
yeah i was arguing for the white guy
just because it really kind of
that casting it's what the project was
talking about it's the sort of power
imbalances that the project was
was talking about so uh
it just seemed to make more sense uh
that way so i guess i've had that sort
of conversation that you
maybe wouldn't think i would be having
um and it was noted by the producer
said look i just think that's the right
way to go in this instance
no no it's interesting because i mean i
think one thing is
people come when we bring to this kind
of thing is that we bring a point of
view that's not often had
and i guess something i'm getting you
want you guys to talk about what you're
doing so well here
is that point of view and exercising it
and
and i guess i'll pass it on to julie now
before i have rodrigo
uh if you're having these conversations
about trying to create a kind of
chemistry
director especially writer director
perhaps i don't know
it's really wednesday's idea of it needs
to be this
and and you're there to try to say well
let's think about this in terms of the
kind of social fabric it creates
i don't cast a film for social
like you know i i i cast a film
with the success of the cr of the story
and um and uh
the the the meat of what is being
the director's intention and at the
heart
so i i can't say that i
push for color when i'm feeling like
it's inappropriate or it's not
serving the characters well am i
answering your question correctly
you know it's not no there's no correct
but no i guess i just wanted this too
because
i think what casting directors do and i
think this is really a chance for people
to hear about this
is offer again a point of view i think
of that as being as much an autistic
person
as as as costume or makeup or anything
else you guys are there to try to
offer as you're saying a supportive
revision
but again i guess kind of arguing
against
um a fixed point of view you know how
off does peter do
and victor's talking about the side door
thing sometimes
making a suggestion that nobody was
expecting if you feel that kind of
freedom is often
not i mean we have chemistry reads
sometimes
to bring some um
you know to bring some of those fears um
you know to sort of temper those um
but if we don't have access to actors
that
are gonna actually come in and do
chemistry reads um
i don't know i think you know casting
directors there's a certain leap of
faith and a sixth sense that we have
when we feel something is really going
to work
and um i'm usually very passionate about
something that i feel strongly about and
i will fight it
till the end and if i lose then you know
um i tried you know but it is usually
the director's vision that i'm servicing
so i know my place and i'm going to just
serve up my best options to him and
ultimately it's his choice
although i do think things can get very
i think directors
uh lives when prepping
a movie being in the middle of
pre-production i mean it's just very
hectic there's a lot of different
questions coming at them different
departments pulling on them
and i think it's good to uh
remind them of something that can kind
of get lost in that whole
milestone of of pre-production
of having a million people asking you
questions
uh if we could just help them
keep their eye on on on the prize so so
to speak like it
it can kind of be i mean just it's it's
i remember michael mann once said to me
said uh
i asked him i was he said i just want to
take a mental diuretic
because it's just so much
just you know he was in the midst of it
all and you and hopefully on some level
we like every department head
can kind of uh just while someone's you
know
bouncing it in there you know against
all all these walls that we can just
help remind them of what they were
trying to achieve if it tends to go a
little bit
if off off course or they need to
remember and i remember we were you said
you wanted this for that but
you know just try to be there to like
every other department head
to help refocus sometimes uh
and re-remind and and i think you know
in the case of casting because you are
casting
you know reading many people for
different roles and
and you know like vicky said this is all
interlaced with all the other
things that you're doing you know it's
always good
to have a casting director to tell you
you know
everyone you've cast in the secondary
professional roles
is a woman in her 30s or
everyone you've cast in the medical
professions
is a latino so you know again a reminder
of what the whole picture looks
like even beyond you know obviously
it's just a reminder does what we're
doing here
reflect the world that the story takes
place in the world that you live in the
world that you want to reflect
and that doesn't mean you have to have a
rainbow of colors
but i think that's where the the casting
director is
is crucial giving you reminding you of
the lay of the land this is where we are
right now
this is where we are this is what it
looks like from an age
sex sexual orientation color
you know ethnicity etc well this usually
brings me to a question i'm going to
start with you what else would you ask
these guys
talk to me about your first conversation
with a casting director on your first
movie
and what and how your eyes are kind of
open to exactly the things you're
talking about
well you know i i'm always playing you
first
you know people are eager to ask the
director for their idea
and i'm always to not give it i'm always
like you read the script
you tell me you know what did you think
what did and you know i want to hear
that
from casting directors and anyone in
every department
including the actors you know if an
actor asks me what's your script about
i would say what do you think it's about
you know i i i
you want here's the thing i feel that
all departments and all creative people
they work from their imagination from
their talent from their experience
i'm always reluctant to say you know
sometimes
uh a casting director will say to me
right off the bat
in the ideal world who would your ideal
three
actors be and i'm like no
let us surprise ourselves you tell me
you know what i mean is like
i'm reluctant i'm reluctant to say what
i think i'm reluctant to be trapped in
my own
thing um
and listen i see it not just with myself
but with you know directors who are
friends or directors that i've
you know that i know and including some
of the greatest directors in the world
they had this idea and then in the end
it wasn't the idea and they were
thrilled
that it wasn't the idea so it's again
it's
you know what do you think ends up being
something that is a director
you should be asking a lot i think in my
not so humble
opinion i like competing for a lack of
reality that's always
always good um
you know your first casting job and what
that was like
and how you were able to sort of make
breakthroughs and
and what's that entail for you
uh my first casting job uh
was on a student film uh that became a
feature film and
so i didn't kind of go through a
traditional route i didn't go through
working for a casting director being an
assistant and
so i i kind of in my first time i
wouldn't really consider kind of being a
part of
the industry this hollywood was kind of
an independent film that we all kind of
you know got together let's make a movie
and
then somebody gave us more money to make
it oh we're making a feature you know so
it's kind of
uh just
throwing the deep into the pool and just
learn to swim
you know um
yeah so it didn't really have anything
to do with the business in a way
they kind of had to do more with film
school and
and an independent group of people um
and i just kind of went on instincts i'd
had
uh just watching tons of movies and
television
shows growing up and kind of always
taking note of actors
and knowing which actors i liked and
uh not really planning to
to kind of do this job but once it got
thrown at me
it was it was a skill set that i kind of
had and didn't quite know i i had so i
had a sense of
actors very early on um
that i saw growing up and i just kind of
referred to that
in my first casting meeting and my first
casting job
and it's not what you're saying is you
kind of basically had an affinity for
this that you didn't realize until you
started doing it
yes i did and i actually had an affinity
for growing up i just wasn't being a
casting director
i was being a movie a movie addict and a
television
addict and you know loving all the tv
shows and the actors and i just had an
affinity for them so
yeah i found out i had an affinity for
it yeah
and julie what was your first job like
in your first conversation with a
director about getting
at this mass the one i can recall
one of my early like you know doing it
on my own
um jobs uh um
it came with an actor
that was somewhat established attached
and that was thrilling the filmmaker had
nurtured
his own relationship with an actor and
an independent film certainly can use
all the help it can get so
to have an actor that other actors
respected i mean he wasn't a household
name but he was a working actor and he
was doing good work and so
um it was jeremy sisto and then
um through being able to promote
and talk about the project with him on
board already
it really helped i realized how
much it facilitated and attracted other
actors that wanted to work with jeremy
and so um you know
talking to agents and having them tell
you that their client is just coming out
and
something that's going to be huge and
you it would be such a coup to have them
in your film and
just kind of like seeing that it was a
little bit of a
a selling um relationship with the agent
with the reps and
us and and and being able to feel all
the different um
ideas being thrown it was it was a
really um
exciting and cool learning experience to
be able to put the pieces together
and and also to have all these names be
thrown at you
and to be able to say you know they're
not right
so that was kind of an interesting thing
to have these
ideas and talent options but
to really service the story and work
with the director and say well this big
name was
you know uh pitch to us but i don't
think they're right
so that was kind of a interesting um
aspect to our job how did it feel when
you first said when you first said that
julia the first time you said it it was
it was actually like uh i felt i mean
it's not like a power thing but i think
i felt
really like this is the job that i'm
meant to do because i really love what i
do
and it's not about names it's not about
movie stars it's about the story
and it's about working collaboratively
with the director
so um it was good it was a good feeling
that's because this is something that i
want to ask everybody anyway
and now it's a good time to answer them
talking about this
about the movies or tv shows that make
you think
there's a place for me in this world
because that's kind of key and it's the
sort of thing
you're all talking about this is love
for for this
this medium and this connection with
talent
that's one of the things that you saw as
kids to make you think
i could be in this place i could do what
these people are doing
there would be some entree for me here
even though as people cover obviously
that wasn't always the case but
you have to almost will it for yourself
for ourselves anyway i wonder
what those examples would be for you
guys
i mean i i you know i grew up in mexico
city so i i did not feel that
uh that sense of exclusion meaning there
was a film industry
and that was quite big um
and then there were you know hollywood
movies and
american tv shows and that just seemed
so remote
you know i didn't even feel excluded
from it
it just that's like watching movies from
uh
from another planet but uh um
but you know i came here to the american
film institute in the 80s
and you know i was a cameraman back then
and the idea of you know mexican
cinematographer was
you know beyond exotic here it was
almost eyebrow raising
although guillermo navarro was already
you know
making his way slowly but but well
um but uh
yeah that was you know i i've had the
pleasure of seeing how that has changed
and how that you know the day came when
when you said oh i need you to see the
work of a mexican cinematographer people
would lean in
you know after navarro and rodrigo
prieto chiva lubesky all those guys
but but luckily growing up i i didn't
feel that sense of exclusion from
you know the own the industry that i in
the country where i was growing up
but he was just talking and it's still
something in you
some ambition was sort of stoked in you
seeing these movies coming from this
other planet
that you were talking about that seemed
kind of remote and so i wonder what
those things would have been
it felt very remote but only because it
was
you know far away and in another country
and not not because
i felt it excluded me as as a
as a result of my ethnicity culture or
color i mean to be frank because you
know it's it's uh
uh you know i i wasn't in that world
um but yes it was it was extremely
remote honestly i i don't think
uh you know for any of us and by us i
mean
you know that generation of mexican
directors who's working here in
hollywood and which
includes some of the greatest filmmakers
of the moment
you know none of us really thought we
would even have an international career
you know the ambition was to make movies
in mexico
so i guess there was a a psychological
barrier that even if you're not being
told
no you can't we were telling ourselves
it's gonna be really hard to get there
you know so yes i think
i think i'm backpedaling already
there was there was so there was a
psychology of i could never get there
you know but i'm sure you know young
people
must have felt it in uh st louis
missouri
you know if does hollywood seem to plan
it away
but also there are things being beamed
from that planet by me torture a
metaphor here
uh movies were things that you saw that
you think yeah i can do this there's a
place in
here i just wonder what some of those
were
you know i i actually uh the
neo-realists
you know the italians because they were
telling stories of
working people middle class people you
know the actors were not necessarily
beautiful
they were not hollywood people a lot of
them were non-actors
so i you know i would say that that
watching
you know all those new italian near
realist movies
made you think oh wow okay well that
that's
that looks like people that that could
be like us like people from mexico city
middle class working class i think
that's the closest thing to say oh
okay it doesn't all have to be hollywood
it could be this
thank you is there were there movies
like that for you as well julia or
things that made you think
i could do this or there's a place for
me here
um well born and raised in los angeles
does not
mean it's an automatic inn to the town's
industry
um i
i did feel i mean it wasn't uncommon for
me
to be um the only person of color in in
an office
but i did feel i never felt uh you know
hyper aware of that
i i did a feel a sense of belonging and
i gravitated towards
um you know like weird movies like david
lynch
and um just uh you know i i liked
um i i liked that there were voices that
were not
exactly making sense and they were just
kind of marching to their own drummer
and so
i was i was like oh i'll join that club
please i feel like i can work with
people like that
so yeah um i i think um
i definitely felt like there was a place
for me
and those are the kind of filmmakers
you're still working with those people
who hear those
weird voices in their head they want to
get onto the screen right yeah that'll
never change
for sure but what about you vicki what
were some of the things that you saw
being such a consumer of this kind of
stuff what would you think well god
i could be in this i could do this kind
of thing because i think for
just want to get this off the young
people watching this who
do have these kinds of questions even
growing up as you said
you'll be in los angeles you're still
because you grew up here doesn't mean
you're in the movie business
so vicky i just wonder what those things
would be for you
um you know i i grew up in la too
my dad worked at the post office my mom
sold encyclopedia we were nowhere near
hollywood in terms of being you know
know that profession
but um i don't know i just always i
never
i mean everything i saw told me i could
work in the
in the industry i didn't see anything
that told me i couldn't
i mean i i just and i i
looked at every type of movie all
types of tv shows um i think
mainly my parents never told us we
couldn't not do something
so for me wanting to be in
show business uh seemed to
make sense and i didn't really look at
any uh
obstacles okay i guess i'm asking this
just because
you guys are all extraordinarily
successful and again i think
what's so interesting about you you all
have very
specific points of view and and
being in a business that as often as not
doesn't seem to welcome points of view
just want the positions to be filled
what it's like for you
to continue to try to work as artisans
that's the fun part i mean you know yeah
i mean i'd
love to bring a point of view to it but
i i don't know that
even with something that's you know
typically hollywood a big budget
hollywood blockbuster
hopefully you can infuse something with
the casting or whatever
that kind of helps give it a little
tweak and
make it a little more interesting than a
let's say a normal hollywood
big blockbuster movie i'm just using
something uh these are kind of generic
terms but
um yeah hopefully just bring a point of
view to whatever
you're working on and hopefully there's
room
in it to bring your point of view
sometimes there's not and you kind of
you kind of have to okay this is what
say this is what this is
and okay you just kind of take a step
back
a little bit you you fight the fight as
as much as you can
and sometimes you don't always win those
fights or people don't always want to
they just want to kind of make the make
the generic
product in a way you know so sometimes
your point of view is
appropriate to things and it may be
less appropriate to other things if that
makes any sense
no it does what i was asking yeah thank
you i wonder if that ends up has that
been the case have you ever rodrigo or
you felt that
sport what you know i always say to to
you know
younger writer directors or writers or
directors
you know if you have some success when
you're starting you have to be careful
that you're not being paid not to be an
artist
because you do get paid not to be an
artist sometimes if
if you know you're a young up and coming
a screenwriter
uh you know they'll pay you a lot of
money to rewrite a script
in a way that it's safe and really not
great
but that's what you're being paid for
you're being paid not to be an artist
don't bring your
dreams your nightmares your sickness
into a project
just write me a pretty picture so yes
you have to be careful that
you know that you're not um you know
you're not leaning into that
and you know yeah to vicky's point you
have to voice your opinion you're also
hired for your opinion they may or may
not pay attention to
it but you have to uh you know you have
to do it and
i think in some cases that's why you
know often
uh you know directors become famous for
being difficult and certainly some heads
of department
and and of course you know it's very
commonly said with women heads of
department
she's difficult no she's not difficult
she's
telling you what she thinks because
that's what you hired her for
um so that's but that you know that's a
problem
in in in this industry and in many
industries you know do you want to speak
up or
do you just want to get along um
and yeah i mean i think uh
you know there are there are directors
who have never compromised
like david lynch for example and all the
power to him
but you know he like orson welles and
many other greats found it
increasingly difficult to make movies
because they did not compromise
so it's also a life choice
what about for you julia have you been
in these situations where it's
you're trying to fight against the idea
of being a product do you see something
more and
in the material and i just wonder how
you deal with that
um i've been fortunate to have very
minimal experience with that
um i when i meet when a material is
presented to me and i read a script i
i spark to the ones that i can see
myself contributing something artistic
to it um
i i gravitate towards something that's
unique
and i gravitate towards directors that
have a collaborative spirit
that are open to me saying what i feel
and i i haven't had a lot of experience
where i had to
fight um i've you know i've
like i said i haven't won every um
battle of a casting choice that i've
presented but
i've had a lot of um i've had a lot of
good fortune with the projects that i've
worked on
and i'm it there's it's there's it's
somewhat intentional
i have to love the material and feel
like
there's something i can add to what's
already on the page
was that the case of last black man in
san francisco
absolutely yes um it's
a unique it was it grabbed me from the
start
um the the people behind it
i could tell it just they were so
passionate about it was super infectious
and um i just really wanted to fulfill
their vision
to um you know to make them happy
for sure there's a situation like that
is again you're talking about
so for me things you guys have in common
is
you guys tend to be really good at
creating communities
and that san francisco and that movie
felt like a real place
and not the real san francisco if you
know what i mean it felt its own thing
and
i've got i think that idea of creating a
world that feels
lived in but distinctive is what you
want to do
yeah i i really credit those guys
um there's really not an inauthentic
beat um you know maybe there there had
to be for some you know like um
you know danny glover even he's a
commercial actor and sometimes
i'm not always keen on having so someone
well known play a character because it
might take you out of the story and then
the authenticness of the story is uh
it you know suffers a little bit but
he's from the bay area
he um is a beloved person
from the communities that the story is
about
he had deep knowledge of what the story
was about and
he really sparked to it as well so it
felt like a
it felt like a a logical marriage for
sure
and for you vicky your first
conversation with quentin tarantine you
guys have felt like you know each other
your entire life
yes i think we were i think we grew up
in the same household just like
20 miles away you know south bay and
and south la yeah i was kind of uh yeah
brother from another mother it was uh it
was
yeah we were the two same nerdy
kids growing up so i felt
i felt an affinity definitely
there's also that thing too again
talking about creating
real communities worlds that feel like
the poster behind you
you've got to build out something for
once upon a time in hollywood
that feels bigger than life but
not unapproachable i mean and and that
must have been sort of the thrill
and a challenge of that yeah i mean i
grew up in la going to hollywood
boulevard taking the bus or my dad would
drop me and my friend's off or
you know i remember the events of the
movie happening um
uh it's just one i wanted to really get
right kind of you know and uh
and yeah it's kind of heightened and but
very realistic at the same time and
uh yeah it was just uh
yeah that was a special one i have a
i have a girlfriend that worked with him
at the video store
that he worked at he knew every title
he knew every shelf that's what she told
me
yeah but i mean this is true and i think
this is for you too i mean this idea of
creating something that feels
real and bigger than life because so
often movies tend to be
this there's these divine things either
one
or the other and i think the kind of
specificity
that that kind of creation demands is
something you saw in those neo-realists
and and something that you want to bring
to the screen as well isn't it
yeah i mean you're especially if you're
making uh
you know contemporary realistic
psychological dramas
you know how do you give it some pop
without it turning into something that
it's not
you know not too flat not too poppy i
mean i i'd say
um a movie like
is it the farewell the one of the dying
grandmother i don't want to get yes
i mean that was that was i thought that
was you know
a very particular world a very
particular tone
and yet really just the middle class
family chinese chinese-americans uh
you know but it it managed to do that um
you know create that that sort of
slightly heightened but totally grounded
you know i think i think uh
you know casting can do that it's always
tricky because you you know you
you know like julia said it's you know
you're always scared oh
can i mix this star with these mortals
you know is that gonna be is there gonna
be glue but you know there's also a
reason why stars are stars is because
they
are great actors and they fit in
beautifully into movies i mean it's
you know i've been in that situation
fortunately where i'm like no no that
that's that
i can't mix you know these two new
people with this
and but it it works you it's uh
you're you're trying to achieve that
something heightened and special without
your casting being artificial and forced
i think that's a that's a constant
battle i think i think that's a constant
whether you're mixing you know known
lesser knowns and
and and and well-known people just yeah
you're always
you want to walk that fine line um
and i don't think that ever goes away
for a casting director no matter how
long you cast you know um
you're always just trying to get that
balance right and just making sure that
you're yeah you're keeping something
real and
as julie said will the addition of that
big name and this small part do this or
to in
i know i've i've been constantly
surprised when it
it no it doesn't all the time you know
it's just uh
but the tension's always there i always
get a little nervous i think it's
it's a little nerve-wracking i think for
all casting directions no matter how
long you you've been doing it is that
the fun of it that's a little
anxiety producing it's definitely
anxiety product i mean
it's anxiety producing and i mean it's
almost like
you ask yourself did i just start
casting yesterday because how come i
don't feel better
about this or how come i don't know
that's the thing
don't you know this by now uh you know
it's uh
yeah yeah well you did it beautifully
and once upon a time in hollywood that
was a big order to fill
and i i got lost in the story so kudos
to you guys
to you and i think and i think uh you
know part of that that
fear that vicky's talking about you
never recuperate from a casting mistake
i mean it really is a knife in your side
forever and ever
and it has nothing it doesn't
necessarily have anything to do with
casting stars and non-stars actors and
non-actors
because you can have you know the right
level of fame
but still cast the role that you're like
oh no that you know we
that that was the wrong tone or she was
too young he was too old
um you know casting can be traumatic
because once you cast the role
it's going to be that face that body
that voice that instrument forever and
ever
so it's it's it can be preoccupying to
put it mildly
it's a it's a heavy burden
you make me sweat just talking about it
here and i don't even do it but
i guess as we're talking about this too
just bring me back to thinking about
the most recent usc amber study about
conclusion again
we're talking about trying the idea
for you guys of creating art but not
ignoring
where the world is and and i guess i
really wonder
if this feels like it's this is the
there's actual momentum behind these the
changes that we're seeing now
because i thought about this a couple
weeks ago unfortunately when
chadwick boseman passed that in the
light of that movie
where has there been this search to say
well
that worked let's do something else like
that it still feels to me like
when movies were cast of color succeed
they feel anomalous rather than part of
a wave
and i just wonder how you guys deal with
that feeling if you if you're in that
camera
well no matter how much you might bring
up something that disproved a notion
uh uh you know a film a particular film
or a particular
actor or whatever i know it's like
people
they just they forget i mean you know
whether it's
uh you can you know quote situations
where well this movie did well in europe
even though it has an all-black cast or
whatever and
you know it's like yeah that's not going
to sell in europe or whatever it is so
it's
i think there are lessons learned and
then they're quickly unlearned um
so i think it's kind of constant battle
kind of going back
you have to you just need another
example and another example and another
example
until maybe something will stick but um
i don't think that's always the the case
so it's an ongoing thing i mean it's
easy right now to say
that you know what the academy has done
is in a moment
of just to get an ex to put an example
it's in a moment of black lives
black lives matter but not really i mean
it's been
you know it's been five six seven years
since the academy has
you know started its its inclusion with
membership and stuff
because it is an ongoing thing i mean
the fact the idea that
one thing is going to solve it you know
the civil rights was
you know 50 years ago plus so
um you know it's it's uh
it's ongoing and uh
you know pay attention because it's not
just
what the academy is asking you to do
but you know don't be on the wrong side
of history
very true would you have any thoughts
about that do i just wonder
what it feels like to you well i don't
i don't know how i mean the survey was a
large span i think it was like from 07
to
recently and i don't
really agree with that survey because i
see the changes around me
um having just watched the us open and
seeing
um you know naomi ozaka win a biracial
woman representing japan
and happens to live in la and of course
serena opened the doors and that was
like 29 years
ago it's a predominantly white sport and
now there's so much color
um i think that it's i i see it
happening
and i poo poo with the naysayers i think
that um i
i see representation on screen and i do
think there's more work to be done
but um i think we're headed in the right
direction and i do think
things like the academy's requirements
help us
hold us accountable keep the
conversation going
and panels like this keep the
conversation going and that's all a good
thing
well that's probably a great point to
know let me thank you guys so much for
doing this i could
really talk about this for a whole lot
longer but nobody's ever seen me
thank you guys so much thanks elvis
hi i'm julia kim thank you for watching
our academy dialogues conversation
check out previous discussions and
subscribe to the oscars channel
for more videos